فيلم لن تستطيع مشاهدته ابدا لا انت ولا
ابنائك ولا احفادك ربما سيتمكن ابناء
احفادك من مشاهدته قد يبدو كلامي مزحه او
ضربا من الخيال لكنه حقيقه فما هو هذا
الفيلم وما قصته اسم الفيلم يطابق معناه
وهو بعنوان مئه سنه الفيلم الذي لن تراه
وهو من اخراج الامير كيروبيرت رودريغيس
وبطوله مواطنه
وتم انتاجه عام 2015
وسيعرض بعد 92 سنه من اليوم قصته ستبقى
سريه بشكل كامل الى حين موعد عرضه المقرر
في الثامن عشر من نوفمبر عام
2215 لكن اعلان الفيلم اظهر انه سيتضمن
مشاهد عن المستقبل صناع الفيلم اودعوه في
كبسوله محكمه الاغلاق بمستودع قصر دوفيك
الثالث عشر في بلده كونياك الفرنسيه
وستفتح تلقائيا في الموعد المحدد هذه
كبسوله عرضت في مهرجان كان السين في عام
2016 وفي العديد من المدن الاخرى في
العالم قبل اعادتها الى كونياكا القائمون
على الفيلم اصدروا تذاكر لحوالي 1000 شخص
من بينهم احفادتش ورودريغيز لحضور العرض
الاول للفيلم وبهذا سيجد احفادهم تحفه
سينمائيه لا تقدر بثمن ليتوارثوها في
مقاله ناقدون ان هذا المنتج السينمائي لم
يرى العالم مثله من قبل ومن سوء الحظ ان
الاجيال الحاليه لن تستطيع مشاهدته ما
رايكم لماذا كل هذه السريه حول هذا الفيلم